bah bonjour à tous et bienvenue donc
merci d'être venu jeter si nous
intéressait pas avoir à ça aujourd'hui
je vais vous parler des mathématiques
pour changer le monde parce que voilà je
pense que il ya un qui veut cette idée
que les mathématiques c'est juste un
truc je crois qu'on le voit au lycée moi
j'ai pas des souvenirs de tiens ça ça va
être super important ça va changer le
monde et en effet je pense que c'est pas
évident de voir le lien entre ce que
vous faites au lycée ou ou même après on
études supérieures c'est pas forcément
évident de voir les impacts sur le monde
du coup assez sympa de ça dont je vais
vous parler aujourd'hui donc alors il ya
pas mal de choses dont j'aurais pu vous
parler et pour tout vous dire quand j'ai
préparé cette plantation j'étais un
petit peu trop ambitieux je pense que
j'étais parti pour une conférence de
2,40 série fin d'une série de 40
épisodes comme j'aime le faire très
rapidement les trucs il ya des trucs un
peu plus classique dans ce qu'on appelle
les mathématiques appliquées ou des
mathématiques
j'ai lu un article récemment qui disait
que les mathématiques sont appliquées
par tout le monde sauf les
mathématiciens appliquée et en fait
c'est pas totalement faux parce qu'en
fait parfois je dis que je suis un
mathématicien théoriquement appliquée
c'est à dire que oui les applications en
effet c'est possible mais enfin c'est en
théorie que c'est applicable et enfin
moi ce qui m'intéresse à la basse et
plus des baux théorème qui ont quelque
chose à voir avec le monde par rapport
aux positions de mathématiciens pure et
donc il ya beaucoup de réflexions qui
ont été faites sur des mathématiques
théoriquement impliqués on prend un
problème qui allait réel et puis on
l'abstrait complètement il ressemble
plus du tout à quelque chose de réel on
travaille un peu dessus et puis parfois
10 vent parfois 50 ans parfois 200 ans
après 350 ans dans le cas de fermat on
découvre des applications de ses
mathématiques
donc voilà ça c'est un petit peu les
grands domaines des mathématiques
appliquées aujourd'hui
puis moi je suis j'en ai oublié beaucoup
mais donc il ya des problèmes de
d'optimisation de façon très générale ou
l'idc on a quelques décisions à prendre
souvent souvent une décision assez
récurrente à prendre donc par exemple
gérer le circuit le réseau électrique
d'électricité et savoir où est ce que
quelqu'un soit les interrupteurs on va
fermer on va ouvrir des choses comme ça
on peut chercher à optimiser par exemple
la structure du réseau plein de points
d'optimisation il ya toute la théorie de
la complexité qui est quelque chose dont
on n'entend pas forcément parler enfin
dont on entend parler assez tard france
dans les études
c'est peut-être un peu dommage la
théorie de la complexité c'est l'étude
de caisse qui est facile et qu'est ce
qui est difficile à faire bizarre dit
comme ça a priori les maths c'est dur
mais en fait il ya des problèmes donc on
a commencé à comprendre que il suffit
que c'est un calcul assez rapide et on
résout le problème quoi et il ya
d'autres problèmes pour lesquels kiss
keynes qui sont des primes récurrents
une typiquement construire un réseau
électrique c'est des problèmes assez
c'est un problème assez récurrent
comment concevoir un réseau et on
aimerait avoir une solution qui résout
tout le temps ce problème et donc c'est
ce qu'on appelle un algorithme comme une
méthode pour toujours résoudre ce
problème est en fait aujourd'hui
énormément de recherches dessus et les
gens n'ont pas réussi à trouver de
manière rapide de toujours résoudre ce
problème est en fait il ya une hypothèse
enfin pape et n'hypothèque une
conjecture c'est à dire quelque chose
qu'on pense que c'est vrai mais on n'a
pas réussi à le démontrer encore qui est
une culture qui s'appelle pv reçus cnp
qui a un problème si vous résolvez vous
gagnez 1 million de dollars est en fait
beaucoup plus
c'est un des problèmes du millenium vous
donne déjà un million de dollars ca ces
données et puis en fait si vous
appliquez aux algorithmes
impressionnante vous pouvez gagner
encore beaucoup plus donc un million de
dollars c'est presque négligeable
donc là il ya tous ces problèmes qui
sont tous les problèmes de cryptographie
aujourd'hui c'est un domaine absolument
fascinant et
extrêmement dynamique énormément de
recherches à faire aujourd'hui en
cryptographie
il en fait on est assez ignorant que
cette fois la complexité la
cryptographie jordi vraiment vraiment
beaucoup de trucs à développer je vous
donne un exemple aujourd'hui il ya un
truc qui est en train de d'émerger des
solutions très très récente et qui date
d'il ya moins de 5 ans souvent sur
comment faire des votes électroniques
sécurisées imaginez sur internet vous
voulez voter et vous voulez vous être
sûr que vous allez voter mais vous vous
l'êtes aussi sûr que votre vote que
votre vote et anonyme
ensuite vous voulez être sûr que tous
les votes sont bien comptabilisés et
pour pouvoir vérifier que tout se passe
bien ça paraît impossible
de prime abord ça ça paraît être un truc
assez et il ya des solutions aujourd'hui
qui utilisent des maths c'est
sophistiqué des histoires de courbes
elliptiques et des groupes ab lien ou
pas il est des plus grosses mats et
derrière tout ça l'a bloqué je sais pas
ce que j'ai entendu parler du bitcoin
laplaud king c'est un peu le truc en ce
moment on travaille un peu dessus c'est
rick ultras qui peut vraiment changer
beaucoup de chose dont j'avais prévu de
parler longuement de la bloquer mais
finalement je veux pas le faire et tous
les problèmes de simulation donc
pourquoi pourquoi faire des simulations
l'idée c'est que on veut tester un
nouveau truc on le faire de l'innovation
mais bien sûr qui dit innovation du
potentiel des chèques et on n'a pas
envie de construire un pont et de voir
pendant cinq ans et le voir s'effondrer
dès que quelqu'un passe dessus et du
coup ce qu'on peut faire c'est essayer
de faire des dépôts ont simulé quoi et
voir comment ils résistent à différents
à différentes conditions
tous les problèmes de simulation sont
toutes sont très importants et puis il
ya toute la théorie des probabilités
alors ça je pourrais vraiment parlé très
longuement parce que c'est mon truc
préféré c'est ça presque à voir avec
qu'est-ce que vous réfléchir qu'est-ce
que croire on pourrait se demander
on pourrait se dire que croire c'est à
dire des trucs vrai mais il est toujours
des moments on se dit assez c'est
probablement vrai mais c'est pas tout à
fait sûr que les vrais et pouvoir
formalisé ce langage certainement la
théorie des probabilités qui permet de
faire ça et ça a énormément
d'applications
donc voilà j'ai énormément de choses
dont j'aurais pu vous parler je vais me
restreindre à un truc aujourd'hui et ça
va faire déjà beaucoup il s'y tenir 45
minutes c'est l'intelligence
artificielle où tu me dit vous avez tous
entendu parler de l'ia c'est
l'intelligence artificielle ce fameux
domaine qui a vraiment le potentiel de
vraiment changer le monde en tout cas
changer énormément de la manière dont on
interagit au quotidien pour le pire ou
pour le meilleur
espérée pour le meilleur est d'ailleurs
une des grandes questions de vos
recherches
c'est comment est ce qu'on fait pour que
ça aille dans le bon sens on va alors
l'intelligence artificielle est
peut-être l'impression que c'est un truc
ultra nouveau et un truc peut-être
d'informatique ou en fait si on retrace
les origines de l'intelligence
artificielle
moi j'aime bien d'autres choses on
voulait paris par effet que je
m'arrêtais un peu sur ça y est donc il
ya pas mal de problèmes en fait que
kelly notions mathématiques ou
informatique ou ces histoires
d'algorithmes permettent vraiment de
résoudre et dont on ne se rend pas
forcément compte quand on est assez loin
de ces domaines ou même lorsqu'on est
dans ces domaines je pense notamment à
cette notion de mise à l'échelle
c'est à dire quand on pense à la société
ont parfois on a des super idée mais il
faut se demander est ce que c'est ça se
met à l'échelle crs que si chacun feint
scission cette solution là est ce que
peut-être que pour trois personnes ça a
bien marché mais est ce que pour un
million de personnes ça va bien marcher
encore et un million de personnes c'est
pas du tout la même chose que trois
personnes donc à cette histoire de mise
à l'échelle et notamment les algorithmes
sont souvent vraiment cette faculté
d'être mise à échelle c'est à dire que
voilà si vous vous avez une nouvelle
idée d'application vous pouvez peut-être
la développer en quelques mois
et puis tout à coup des bleus faire une
vidéo youtube
voilà tout à coup vous avez
potentiellement des des milliers voire
des millions de personnes qui sont
capables d'utiliser votre solution
cette mise à l'échelle c'est quelque
chose d'assez stupéfiants et qui apporte
enfin qu'est pas énormément de précédent
dans l'histoire
il ya eu d'autres notions dont on
reparlera de juger pas trop insister sur
les autres motions je veux revenir sur
les origines de l'intelligence
artificielle
je pense que vraiment voyez il ya des
trucs avant turing mais vraiment le alan
turing jeu pas si vous avez vu le film
imiter schengen parle de tueries non
limitée chaîne game il parle pas du tout
des plus grandes idées de turing souvent
très peu
je pense l'une des grandes idées
notamment des turing c'est l'idée de
caisse que faire des mathématiques
qu'est-ce que penser qu est-ce que
qu'est-ce que réfléchir qu'est-ce que
faire une déduction logique kss kss kss
que qu'est-ce que réfléchir qu'est-ce
que faire quelque chose est en fait il a
donc c'est une question vraiment
vraiment philosophique à la base un et
sarah s'adresser d'autres questions
aussi de logique de savoir qu'est ce qui
est vrai qu est ce qu il faut comment
comment définir logique formelle des
questions comme ça et donc pour répondre
à ces questions et s'est dit on va
imaginer quelque chose qui fait quelque
chose qui fait et ce quelque chose qui
fait c'était une machine qui est
purement mécanique elle fait des trucs
et suit des règles des instructions très
précises
elle ne fait que suivre ses instructions
donc ça ça l'a amené à formaliser la
notion de machines avec plein plein de
raisonnement qui vont qui vont avec
mais cette idée de match de machine de
turing
c'est peut-être une des idées les plus
révolutionnaires de l'histoire des idées
france
d'un point de vue philosophique mais
aussi d'un point de vue technologique
puisque ça conduit à toute l'industrie
des nouvelles technologies et notamment
par exemple vos téléphones ou
ordinateurs sont des machine de turing
et exploite en gros les idées de tueries
et en particulier dans dans cet article
c'est pas tout à fait de ça dont il
parle oui il en parle un petit peu pour
pouvoir définir ce qu'est une machine la
question qu'il qui pose vraiment c'est à
ce que les machines peuvent penser c'est
je pense que c'est vraiment la question
qui obsède un petit peu turenne il veut
savoir s'il peut faire des machines qui
sont vraiment capables de penser ce qui
est intéressant c'est que voilà on a
aujourd'hui on a tendance à rattacher sa
tête à l'informatique ou mathématiques
mes skis cet article de turini la
publier dans un truc sur la psychologie
la philosophie c'est vraiment quelque
chose je pense qu'ils ne s'arrêtent pas
au juste monde des mathématiques est
donc dans cet article il se pose
énormément de questions fascinantes
d'ailleurs il définit ce qu'est une
machine est en fait il se dit que mon
alors pensé c'est assez vague c'est
assez difficile et va y avoir de la
résistance
la part de d'autre du coup ils réduisent
à un problème plus facile à répondre
peut donner une réponse un peu plus
clair qui est le test de turing qui est
qu'ils sont de savoir est ce que une
machine peut se comporter de manière
indiscernable d'un humain jusqu'à dans
une communication
alors on imagine que si on veut parler à
machine directement on verrait que l a
pas des yeux doux choix
du coup ce qu'il imagine c'est plus un
chat avec avec avec une machine et du
coup la question qui pose c'est est-ce
que lorsqu'on leucate avec une machine
on sera capable de discerner le fait de
se dire ah tiens c'est stéphane machine
où est ce qu'on va se dire en fait elle
est vraiment indiscernable d'un humain
et je sais pas si je suis en train de
parler un humain ou une machine il est
pas mal réflexion autour de tout ça et
la fin de cet article la section 7 de
cet article qui est vraiment un de mes
morceaux préférés de littérature dans un
cet article il se définit fait la
remarque suivante il se dit moi je
connais un truc qui résout le test de
turing
c'est le cerveau humain est le cerveau
humain il est complexe et une certaine
complexité
il ya des études de neurosciences à
l'époque et qui montraient que le nombre
de synapses de connexions synaptiques
entre les neurones était de l'ordre de
10 puissance 15 10 puissance 15 c'est un
million de milliards
en fait les estimations c'était entre
distance 11 et 18 ans 15
bon là ça fait beaucoup et il se dit que
pour atteindre cette complexité
soit on essaie de l'écrire vous prenez
un bout de papier essayer de décrire le
cerveau et ça ça va être très long parce
qu'en fait il va falloir disent
probablement quelque chose comme 10
puissance 11 aux dispenses 15 pages pour
pouvoir décrire le cerveau imaginez un
livre de 10 puissance 11 pages
c'est un méga livré aujourd'hui il ya
des modèles déjà qu'on utilise par
exemple en astrophysique tout où c'est
vraiment des maxi modèle des trucs qui
font du queyran on aura peut-être pas de
10 puissance 15 pages mais on est facile
maintenant dans les discussions ce 9 des
très gros bouquin
et du coup l'idée de turing c'est de se
dire que pour pouvoir et faire un truc
qui soit comme le cerveau humain au clic
et les facultés du cerveau humain
quelque part il va falloir que le code
de la machine soit pas écrit par des
humains parce que les humains sont trop
limitées d'une certaine manière il se
dit que il faut que la machine soit
capable de s'écrire elle même ça c'est
vraiment la grande île et des machines
il dit que les bonnes machines qui vont
résoudre l'open d'intelligence
artificielle sont des appels des
learning machine c'est à dire des
machines qui sont capables d'apprendre
c est en gros là la grande équation qui
permet de l'intelligence artificielle
s'est il faut du machine learning
mais en fait il faut aussi quelque chose
en plus que le machine learning faut
pouvoir exploiter quelque chose pour
pouvoir guider
cet apprentissage notamment dans
l'article il s'inspire du cerveau humain
qui est guidé
suivez vous avez vous allez à l'école au
lycée peut-être à polytechnique j'espère
et voilà pour toute cette phase en fait
on vous donne des données et vous avez
votre algorithmes de machine learning
quelque part dans le cerveau qui va
utiliser ces données pour pouvoir
développer une certaine forme
d'intelligence artistes en l'occurrence
n'a pas partie du ciel mais pour
l'intelligence artificielle il faut
aussi à la fois est ce qu'on appelle
maintenant du big data et d'une machine
learning la grande architecture
aujourd'hui pour résoudre ce problème
c'est un c'est un truc qu'on appelle un
réseau de neurones
ça c'est très très vieux en fait c'est
des mathématiciens qui se sont dits dans
les années 50
bon ben ok et les idées turing
maintenant comment est ce qu'on les met
en place comment est-ce qu'on crée un
système qui va se mettre à jour
automatiquement et qui va permettre
d'apprendre
du coup l'inspiration forcément fin
d'ailleurs turing s'inspire du cerveau
humain les tissus à l'époque on
s'inspirait également du cerveau humain
ils vont se dire que ce qu'on peut faire
imaginez c'est un ensemble de neurones
et des signaux qui vont être un des
liens entre ces neurones et des signaux
qui vont être envoyés à travers à
travers ces liens donc tout ça c'est en
fait c'est simuler c'est purement
aujourd'hui ses soins très simuler et
des projets d'heure pour faire un truc
plus hardware qui ressemble plus au
cerveau humain mais souvent ces essais
c'est entièrement simuler et l'idée
c'est juste voilà on a un ensemble de
neurones qui sont simulés et chaque
neurone en fonction de ce qu'ils du
message qui reçoit va envoyer des
messages aux autres neurones et le
signal va se propager
chaque neurone prend en compte tout ce
qu'il tout ce qu'on lui envoie comme
message pour décider d'un message envoyé
neurones suivant et ce qui va être
appris en fait ce sont les connexions
neuronales la manière dont les neurones
vont se décider d'envoyer un message à
qui juste en choisissant d'envoyer plus
ou moins de messages à l'un ou à l'autre
on est capable de changer un peu un peu
le programme gros et si on lui a donné
des données du monde
il y sera capable ainsi de s'ajuster au
monde et du coup d'exploiter our
l'information du monde pour pouvoir
créer sa propre intelligence sommes donc
l'idée un peu sous la cendre de tout ça
avec ces réseaux de neurones en fait
c'est l'objectif qu'on aimerait vraiment
faire c'est essayer de pouvoir donner
directement des données brutes à aux
intelligences artificielles
en fait comme nous que nous nous en fait
si vous réfléchissez les données
auxquelles on avait vraiment excellent
c'est le toucher la vue l'odorat et août
tous les sens et en fait d'une certaine
heure on utilise tout ça pour mettre à
jour notre cerveau pour essayer de mieux
comprendre et terminer notre
compréhension du monde et pour cela en
fait ce qu'on prend ses soins des
données brutes en entrée et
après on essaie d'avoir une
représentation sémantique typiquement
quand vous lisez un texte
en fait les caractères il importe peu
d'ailleurs s'ils sont écrits à une
machine à écrire ou à un ou à la main ça
change pas grand chose parce que d'une
certaine manière on a une représentation
sémantique qui est indépendante de la
manière dont le texte est représenté une
grosse partie de la recherche
aujourd'hui en intelligence artificielle
ce qu'on appelle le futur learning c'est
essayer de trouver des bonnes
représentation sémantique des données
donc ça ça a énormément d'applications
ça rend le potentiel de changer beaucoup
de choses dans la manière dont on vit le
pardon ça c'est un article de jeu c'est
plus la date et 2017 croise assez récent
donc ce qu'est ce que ça dit c'est qu'en
fait ils ont développé une intelligence
artificielle qui à partir de photos il
capable de diagnostiquer le cancer de la
peau et les performances de cette
intelligence artificielle sont
maintenant d'un niveau du même niveau
que les dermatologues que les
professionnels ça ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui pour diagnostiquer des
cancers
vous avez plus besoin d'aller enfin
certains cancers en tout cas vous n'avez
plus besoin d'aller chez le médecin vous
avez juste prendre une photo rapidement
avec vos smartphones tout ça peut être
directement dans votre nouveau téléphone
et vous pouvez faire on peut faire
maintenant du diagnostic qui se met
complètement à l'échelle on peut y avoir
accès et si vous connaissez un petit peu
parce que souvent le problème des
concerts c'est ce diagnostic le moment
du diagnostic si le diagnostic est très
précoce c'est souvent ça se soigne
beaucoup beaucoup mieux c'est et ça
coûte beaucoup moins cher que si on est
un diagnostic trop tardif donc ça c'est
vraiment le potentiel une solution très
simple qui se met à l'échelle et qui est
capable de sauver beaucoup de vies un
coût très faible
donc quand je compare d'intelligence
artificielle souvent en a il ya deux
clichés
je pense d'ailleurs le film imitation
game est pas le cliché le cliché d'un
mathématicien d'un informaticien qui
serait très froid très qui aurait aucune
émotion et qui sera pas capable de
comprendre les autres
en fait une intelligence artificielle
aujourd'hui est déjà plus capable j'ai
des humains pour reconnaître les
émotions chez d'autres personnes
donc ça c'est une étude c'est 2015 2015
c'est quasiment vieux chêne de la
recherche dans le domaine et en 2015
déjà sur la connaissance de l'émotion à
partir d'image les intelligences
artificielles faisaient déjà mieux que
les humains donc vous pouvez imaginer
les conséquences qu'on pourrait avoir de
ça on peut avoir par exemple des tchats
bottes va peut-être à terme peut-être
pas encore mais peut-être à terme on
pourra voir des tchats bottes qui sont
capables de s'adapter à votre humeur et
du coup ce sera peut-être assez plaisant
d'interagir avec ces intelligences
artificielles
c'est un peu spéculatif mais je pense
que c'est pas complètement des ans
il ya un autre truc qui est assez
intéressant à faire c'est essayer de
partir de la représentation sémantique
et de générer des données brutes alors
ça si vous y réfléchissez
c'est c'est un gros si vous voulez
écrire un livre où je sois si vous
voulez faire un processus créatif faire
un tableau où je sais pas trop quoi
c'est un peu le travail que vous faites
vous essayez d'avoir une des quelques
idées et ensuite de développer ses idées
pour avoir des trucs une histoire à
raconter aux crises comme ça et ça les
intelligences artificielles sont
vraiment devenus maintenant souvent même
assez forte dans ce domaine nous par
exemple
donc là il ya deux images à l'écran il
ya une de ces deux images qui a été
généré de toutes pièces par une
intelligence artificielle de nvidia
alors question qui pensent que l'homme
est celui qui a été générée par
l'intelligence artificielle générés par
intelligence artificielle l'homme qui
pense que c'est la femme ok
bah en fait ce qui se passe c'est que
les les deux images en fait sont générés
par humains standardisés
je pense que c'est assez impressionnant
alors il ya des trucs encore plus
impressionnant aujourd'hui avec la
recherche parce que bon maintenant on a
une flèche d'un côté non c'est faire la
flèche de l'autre côté et du coup on
peut on peut avoir cette communication
qui se fait entre les données brutes et
les représentations sémantique de ces
données et ça ça des trucs à ses
conséquences assez folle où par exemple
aujourd'hui on est capable capable de
faire de ce genre d'addition qui est
assez de ce téléphone ne comprend un
homme avec des lunettes
on retire on fait moins un homme sans
lunettes et on fait plus une femme sans
lunettes on obtient une femme avec
lunettes ça c'est des trucs je connais
pas d'explication de sa salle et je
pense que c'est encore un problème
ouvert ma connaissance d'expliquer
pourquoi pourquoi ça marche alors
quelques quelques précisions donc là je
parle de soustraction et l'addition
comme vous l'imaginez sepa et des
soustractions et des additions de
nombres entiers naturels
en fait c'est des additions vectorielle
donc c'est un truc vous avez vu les
vecteurs j'imagine et donc les vecteurs
en fait donc souvent l'image il avait vu
les vecteurs de dimensions de deux qui
sont des fils et des flèches dans le
plan s'est vu vecteur de dimension 3
souvent si vous faites est fait ghalem a
un truc en physique fait ça et bien en
fait on peut faire des vecteurs un très
grande dimension et en fait
l'intelligence artificielle fait des
additions vectorielle en dimensions 50
peut-être plus mais c'est souvent dans
ses grandes dimensions qui font ces
additions c'est c'est donc ce qu'ils
font c'est qu'ils prennent la
représentation sémantique la
représentation sertic c'est un vecteur
de dimensions 50 ou plus et avec cette
représentation sémantique et donc ils
ont un vecteur et il faut il regarder
les représentations antiques des trois
des trois types de photos ils font cette
addition vectorielle dans l'espace des
sémantique et ensuite ils retraduit ce
qu'ils obtiennent un vecteur d'un espace
désertique
ensuite il génère une photo à partir de
cette représentation sémantique et ça
correspond à l'intuition c'est
je pense que c'est encore un mystère et
j'espère qu'il va pas durer longtemps et
qu'on va avoir une explication
un autre truc est absolument fascinant
c'est un travail de chercheur chez
facebook et l'université pierre et marie
curie
ce qu'ils ont fait c'est c'est vraiment
fussent ils ont donné à une intelligence
artificielle plein de textes en français
à lire ils nous ont donné plein de
textes en anglais à lire mais les textes
et pas des traductions les uns des
autres
je suis pas un molière et d'un côté vous
avez lu shakespeare de l'autre je sais
pas trop quoi en fait ils n'ont pas lu
des textes anciens mais un simple idée
ensuite ils ont demandé à une
intelligence artificielle de se
fabriquer des espaces de sémantique des
représentations sémantique de ce qu'ils
voyaient en français des représentations
sémantique de ce qu'il voyait en anglais
congo il retirait un petit peu du sens
des mots qu'ils disaient
ensuite il avait du coup l'espace des
scientiques en france l espace d
sémantique en anglais et en fait ils ont
essayé de trouver une façon de coller
ces deux espaces donc là c'est
l'histoire de deux rotations dans des
espaces de très grande dimension
est ce que ce cas c'est merveilleux
c'est que non seulement ils ont réussi à
recoller assez bien mais ensuite ça leur
fait un canal d'irrigation ils peuvent
prendre un mot anglais
regardez sa représentation sémantique en
anglais qui va être un vecteur traduire
cela en sa représentation sémantique en
français tu est un autre vecteur et
ensuite trouver à quoi il correspond en
tant que mots français et ce cas c'est
fou c'est que cette façon d'apprendre le
sens des mots cc6 ça atteint des dons
qui disent que leur modèle et meilleur
kobe que toutes les autres approches qui
avaient été testées pour certaines
langues
certaines paires de langues dans toutes
les langues se ressemble un petit peu si
elles sont trop différentes l'instant on
n'y arrive pas mais si toi ça c'est la
meilleure façon qu'on a aujourd'hui
d'apprendre certaines traductions de
mots c'est quand même assez fou que
c'est c'est juste en lisant vous
inférées la sémantique des mots et vous
vous voyez deux espaces de sémantique
qui se ressemblent et qui sont voie de
bien c'est assez stupéfiant
ça ça me fait dire aussi que on va
parfois on parle de les machines ont
besoin de beaucoup beaucoup de données
pour apprendre en fait cet exemple ils
montrent que en fait fallu dire des
textes écrits y en a énormément et on
peut faire lire wikipedia une
intelligence artificielle autant de fois
qu'on veut avec toutes ces données si je
sais donner l'impression que si on fait
vraiment du très bon machine learning
d'une très bonne intelligence
artificielle
on pourrait être incapable d'un ferry
beaucoup de sens de tout ce qu'on lit
sur wikipédia d'avoir vraiment peut-être
une compréhension surhumaine surhumaine
encense deux niveaux au-dessus de
l'homme de la langue peut-être on n'y
est pas du tout aujourd'hui
donc ça en fait ça marche très bien pour
les traductions de mots mais maintenant
pour les traductions de phrases ça fait
moins bien en fait il ya énormément de
problèmes dès qu'on essaie de d'inférer
de la sémantique de trucs plus compliqué
comme un paragraphe où tout un livre
mais on en est encore au début ça c'est
un papier qui date de novembre 2010 7,6
me trompe pas alors ça
des problèmes ça pose aussi des
problèmes donc il ya microsoft qui a
lancé un peu sur ces idées qui a lancé
un compte twitter qui s'appelle take
tweets et ils l'ont laissé sur twitter
ce qui est une mauvaise idée parce que
en fait moi les gens ont interagi avec
elle et va il y eut des trolls sur
internet qui ont ils ont poussé à qui
l'on ment gros motivé pour dire des
trucs politiquement pas très correct
donc là il dit juste ouais si la menace
personne à dieu ça a été dur a dit
calmez-vous je suis gentille personne je
sais juste que je déteste tout le monde
ça c'est pas du tout le pire qu'elle a
écrit hier je vous ai mis un truc ici
pour être politiquement correct et je
voulais pas mais bon il ya des histoires
strict de hitler nazis tout ce que vous
voulez et ça c'est un problème beaucoup
plus fondamental c c'est le problème de
qu'est-ce qu'on veut que les iaf fonds
et quelles sont les données avec
lesquels qu'est-ce qu'on pousse les ja à
faire là clairement être sur twitter si
vous voulez 38 et j'ai envie de dire que
c'est une stratégie optimale quoi de
parler de nazisme et de trucs comme ça
nous y aller prendre les ja qu'on va
développer au fur et à mesure elles vont
être lâchés dans la nature d'un moment
alors lâché dans la nature ça va être
juste c'est juste juste dire être mises
en place quelque part et de voir
interagir avec du monde extérieur
qu'est-ce qu'on les pousse à faire et
comment est ce qu'on fait on peut être
sûr qu'on les pousse pas à faire des
trucs mauvais parce que les lésions en
fait sont pas en terme de ce qu'on parle
de fonction objective souvent en termes
de fonctions de file de ce qu'elles
veulent elles sont pas si différents de
nous en fait les ja elle fonctionne
souvent par un système de deux de
carottes et de bâtons c'est à dire que
quand elles ont un score quelque part
qu'elle cherche à maximiser ce score il
s'habille payer quelques de manière
assez bizarre mais quand on lui dit que
oui dit qu'elle fait un bon job un bon
job sur tweets sur twitter mais
heureusement c'est juste être conduite
et souvent ça va leur faire dire que
c'est ce qu'il faut faire
augmenter ils se disent qu'à chaque fois
qu'on leur donne leur disent que c'est
bien ce qu'ils font ils vont vouloir
continuer à le faire chaque fois qu'on
leur dit que c'est pas bien ils vont
moins le faire alors si c'est un humain
bonne fin nous souvent on est éduqué par
d'autres humains et qu'ils nous disent
que je pas tuer c'est mal tu essaies mal
faites pas ça mais une intelligence
artificielle
il faut se poser la question de quelques
quel va être l'environnement autour
qu'est-ce qui est ici les gens qui vont
les pousser à faire x ou y est je pense
notamment par exemple moi je vais
revenir un peu plus tard il ya pas mal
de questions qui se posent autour d'une
application d intelligence artificielle
en pratique et ça pose plein de
questions de philosophie morale de
questions éthiques fondamentales par
exemple aux etats-unis ils ont commencé
à utiliser un système une intelligence
artificielle pour prendre des décisions
sur alors c'était super pour nous
c'était pour savoir si un détenu avait
un grand risque de récidive ou pas
qu'ils ont déployés cette intelligence
artificielle qui avait des traits qui
avait l'air même d'être au niveau
presque surhumain meilleur que l'humain
pour prédire si les détenus allaient
refaire réfère une récidive
mais après ils ont analysé un petit peu
les données de ses prises de décision et
se sont rendus compte qu'en fait
l'intelligence artificielle mettez était
été assez raciste d'une certaine manière
puisque elle mettait toujours en gros en
fonction de la couleur de peau de la
personne
ouah disait bon bah les noirs sont des
récidivistes et les blancs sont pas des
récidivistes
en gros je simplifie donc ça ça pose
vraiment des problèmes éthiques c'est
est ce qu'on a le droit d'avoir une
incidence artiste qui prend des
décisions de justice en fonction de la
couleur de faim parce que quelque part
va y avoir la photo de la personne et on
autorise intelligence artificielle a
utilisé la photo de la personne du coup
elle peut inférer plus plein de choses
d'où il ya tout ce domaine de recherche
sur qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'est ce
qu'une intelligence artificielle qui ne
serait pas racisme qui ne serait pas
biaiser le glanage parle
la couleur de peau mais j'aurais pu
parler des inégalités hommes-femmes
enfin tout ce que vous voulez la manière
dont on s'habille aussi comment est ce
qu'on voit là c'est des questions si on
veut appliquer mettre les intelligences
artificielles en pratique il va falloir
quelque part et répondre à ces questions
mais en fait répondre à ces questions
demandent vraiment de dalé dont dans le
formalisme et en fait c'est la recherche
en mathématiques aujourd'hui que de
trouver que de définir le racisme c'est
vraiment des articles de recherche qui
sont publiés même beaucoup tous les ans
qui se posent la question de caisse que
racisme et comment est-ce qu'on lutte
contre le racisme c'est les grandes
questions de recherche en mathématiques
appliquées alors
alors quand je dis ça je suis en train
de de dire beaucoup de balles des
influences artificielle faut se rendre
compte aussi que si c'est pas une
interview d'artistes qui prend la
décision ce sera un juge enfin humains
ou plusieurs humains mais il ya pas mal
de recherches qui montrent que les
humains aussi en fait on est très en
cause un poney inconsciemment pas mal
baisées aussi où on va prendre des
décisions qui vont être biaisé sans
qu'on s'en rende compte même si on pense
qu'on n'est pas raciste n'est pas biaisé
donc voilà c'est celle ci une question
qui se pose vraiment de savoir comment
est ce qu'on prend des décisions
équitables et sachant que l'humain a
cédé choffat vraiment pas mal de défauts
l'autre grand problème de l'intelligence
artificielle
aujourd'hui enfin certains diraient que
c'est même pas un problème encore mais
il ya il ya des gens qui pensent que
l'intelligence artificielle peuvent
vraiment devenir dangereuse que peut
vraiment devenir quelque chose qui nous
échappe un petit peu et qui nous
manipulent d'une certaine manière pour
arriver à des fins à certaines fins donc
je suis pas si vous avez vu le film x
makeena qui est vraiment hors qui hier
s'est un peu trop futuriste pour être
actuel mais c'est une question qui se
pose vraiment de savoir comment est-ce
qu'on conçoit des intelligences
artificielles qui vont nous sauver nous
obéir c'est un peu difficile à dire
parce que parfois on sait pas ce qu'on
veut on dit pas ce qu'on veut
où va sinon comprend l'algorithme
youtube en fait c'est une intelligence
artificielle qui prend déjà beaucoup de
décisions pour nous qu'il nous montre ce
que nous propose des vidéos et fait du
très bon blog du coup on attend sa palme
à cliquer sur les vidéos qui sont
proposés par l'incidence artificielle de
youtube il ya toute cette et tout un
domaine de recherche qui s'appelle haïti
où la sécurité en silence artificielle
qui se posent cette question de comment
est ce qu'on fait des intelligences
artificielles qui voilà qui qui ne
peuvent pas être dans le choix d'une
certaine manière ou qui ya pas mal de
recherches là dessus j'aimerais insister
un peu plus sur deux intelligences
artificielles en particulier qui je
pense aujourd'hui son qui sont parmi les
entités les plus puissantes du monde je
faisais me faisait parler de cette
histoire de mise à l'échelle
le problème c'est souvent un individu a
pas ce pas de risque et de mise à
l'échelle envies d'ailleurs parce que
voilà on est juste un individu ici on
prend des algorithmes maintenant comme
facebook ou youtube
ces algorithmes une petite modification
de ses algorithmes va avoir des
conséquences quasiment immédiate sur
potentiellement des millions voire des
milliards de personnes et il ya vraiment
la question qui se pose de savoir
du coup comment est ce qu'on nous dit
ces intelligences artificielles mais moi
j'irais même plus loin à savoir
qu'est-ce qu'on veut que ces
intelligences artificielles font face
par exemple il ya aujourd'hui donc c'est
pas mal des on dit malheureusement mais
apparemment l'algorithme de youtube va
surtout chercher à maximiser le nombre
de vues ou le witch time pour le temps
passé sur youtube ça c'est une fonction
un objectif qui a l'air assez anodine
c'est socialement souvent à accepter à
peu près que de dire bon ben voilà c'est
une entreprise maximiser nombre de vue
qu'elle fait s'appelle l'art scandaleux
mais ça ça des dérives c'est à dire que
par typiquement si vous étiez une
intelligence artificielle aux commandes
de youtube et que vous vouliez maximiser
le witch time by high et et vidéo qui
marche mieux que d'autres
il ya des vidéos voulait donner les gens
cliquer et recliquer requis cliquer
dessus et c'est pas forcément les vidéo
intelligente on va dire ça
dupouy voilà est-ce qu'il faut pas
quelque part ne pas amener les gens à
regarder des vidéos ouais
conspirationnistes ou sais pas trop quoi
je pense que là si on veut enfin si si
si cette question est vraiment
importante à vos yeux le plus gros
impact que vous pourrez que quelqu'un
pourrait avoir si l'algorithme de
youtube il suffit d'une petite
modification de cet algorithme pour
changer beaucoup beaucoup la manière
dont par exemple les sciences peuvent
être perçus dans société
je pense que voilà c'est cesser ses
algorithmes ont beaucoup de pouvoir avec
des grands pouvoirs viennent de grandes
responsabilités tant que je pense en
tout cas voilà les petits effets sur ses
algorithmes peut avoir de grandes
conséquences
et ça ça a été ok une une recherche qui
est qui devrait être beaucoup plus
relayé à mon sens ce qui a été fait par
des chercheurs de facebook et donc la
question que se sont posée c'est est ce
que en changeant le l'algorithme de
young de newsfeed en essayant de mettre
un peu plus de messages positifs ce que
vous savez le newsfeed sur facebook
ils sont sélectionnés voulez vous voyez
pas tous les messages qui passe de tous
vos amis
une sélection par l'algorithme de
facebook des messages qui vont
apparaître et que vous allez voir
donc facebook décide en partie de ce à
quoi vous serez exposés tous les jours
et donc il ya eu cette étude là qu'ils
essaient de savoir si une petite
modification de cette de cet algorithme
de facebook en par exemple en favorisant
légèrement les postes facebook qui sont
bienveillants ou qui ont des mots avec
des mots joyeux comment dire et qui
diminuait du coup l'apparition de postes
avec des trucs négatifs
ils ont fait cette expérience juste en
changeant sa et se sont rendus compte
que les gens qui étaient à qui on forte
en donner des messages plus positifs
avaient tendance à mettre eux aussi des
messages plus positif al'inverse ils ont
fait la même expérience où ils ont cette
fois augmenté le nombre de postes
négatif dans le newsfeed et comme on
peut s'y attendre
les gens se sont mis à mettre des
messages beaucoup plus négatif vous
pouvez changer l'humeur de toute une
nation avec une petite modification d'un
algorithme donc voilà c'est qu'il ya en
philosophie morale il ya un truc qu'on
appelle l'utilitarisme laisse pas si
vous connaissez donc l'idée de
l'utilitarisme si une philosophe qui
m'aura le normatif un peu façon de dire
bon en fait ça serait pas si mal comme
fonction objectif le but de judaïsme
c'est de maximiser le bonheur global ça
paraît pas scandaleux
en fait ça c'est ce qu'en 2 pour des
raisons sur lesquelles je peux venir
mais c'est pas mal comme comme fonction
objectifs a priori je pense que si on
vous dit que plus de bonheur c'est quand
même pas mal
bah pour un utilitariste se rendre
compte de ça se rendre compte que un
petit une petite modification sur
l'algorithme de facebook peut rendre
toute une nation beaucoup plus heureuse
ça donne quand même envie de 6,6 un
petit bouton l'appuyer qui permet de
rendre les gens plus on a envie de crier
dessus que je pense qu'avec les
questions se posent vraiment peu à la
fois pour facebook et pour youtube
qu est ce qu on veut que nos sociétés
dans nos sociétés et ce qu'il faudrait
pas justement profité du fait que ses
algorithmes ont beaucoup de pouvoir pour
améliorer autant que possible nos
sociétés nous voilà donc j'en viens à un
peu la conclusion de cet exposé ce que
j'espère vous avoir montré c'est que
vaille et dvd et tout cet angle de
recherche toute cette recherche en
intelligence artificielle aujourd'hui à
énormément de conséquences et c'est
souvent des questions qui sont vraiment
difficiles
c'est des questions sur lesquelles si
vous y allez pas avec la rigueur et la
puissance des mathématiques
il y aura beaucoup de de flou de
contresens ça peut être très très
difficile typiquement de savoir ce qu'on
veut en société et il ya une norme de
recherche justement pour essayer de
mieux comprendre ce que les gens veulent
c'est la question la philosophie morale
et descriptive normative et c'est
d'inclure ça dans les indigences
artificielle et toute cette grossière
sur comment formaliser des notions comme
l'équité comme
le fait de biaiser un algorithme de
faire peut-être la discrimination
positive
il ya toutes ces notions là qui sont
très compliquées il faut il faut il faut
y réfléchir il faut bien y réfléchir et
surtout pour pouvoir aussi mettre à
l'échelle toutes ces idées le langage
dans la thématique est quelque chose de
très puissant et il ya énormément de
recherches à faire dans ce domaine
j'espère que vous intéresserait que
voilà merci
[Applaudissements]